this is a production of Cornell
University
let me proceed I'm not going to talk
about photosynthesis much but I'm going
to talk about photosynthetic organisms
and their their lifestyle and it's the
what I'm going to talk about is this
business this inning and the Yankees
time which is that there are cells like
cyanobacterial cells that can perform
these two amazing and important energy
related processes one producing energy
in the other one utilizing energy and
that's what is interning and photos into
the nitrogen fixation and let me just
start by saying something that probably
everybody in this room knows but this is
the basis for this study is that
photosynthesis especially oxygenic
photosynthesis produces oxygen nitrogen
fixation depends on an enzyme that's
exquisitely sensitive to oxygen so
having the two things happen in the same
space at the same time or not this has
been a long time question that people
have been asking and what I will tell
you now is what we have learned over the
last 15 years or so studying a
specialized sign of bacterial cells this
is my favorite slide always to remind
myself and also when I teach students is
that oxygen acuerdo synthetic
photosynthesis nature divides this
amazing system long time ago its carbon
negative it reduces the byproduct oxygen
that we all depend on and it makes good
stuff like this carbohydrates that's the
basis for basis for life as we know on
this planet and what the other thing
that I want to point out is that the
basics machinery for photosynthesis
evolved in cyanobacteria as far as
oxygen in photosynthesis is concerned
and remain the same over many millions
years of our billions of years of
evolution so that what we see in implant
systems the basic machinery of
photosynthesis remains the same as what
were what was what evolved into a sign
bacteriol system so what are
cyanobacteria I am assuming that
majority of the folks here are our plant
biologists so cyanobacteria are microbes
they are prokaryotes oxygen equal
synthetic flow carriers they are the
progenitors of chloroplasts most
abundant fossils in precambrian drugs
they have been around for many billion
years and found everywhere on the planet
what is going to be important today is
this feature that they are the only
known bacteria which circadian
lifestyles and this will play an
important role in what I'm going to
discuss today now cyanobacteria I'm just
going to coat stiff and your Gold's book
up live from that it says that the 2.5
to 2 billion years ago cyanobacteria
thrive by using water the most abundant
source of hydrogen in the environment
and oxygen was a byproduct but here is
the important sentence life began to
change the planet the planet the way we
know it the the the oxic environment it
primarily the cyanobacteria responsible
for it one of the consequence was this
business of all iron two-plus becoming
iron three-plus precipitate the ocean
bottom basically for biology this is a
big conundrum because with the basic
machinery of life was was dependent on
iron two-plus but then all of a sudden
we don't have any of that and everybody
including human beings we have to invent
all sorts of ways of capturing iron and
using it the appropriate level and then
nearly over a billion years oxygen they
will build up dissolve in water is kept
in the atmosphere 20.6 percent sometimes
it was even higher and stage was set for
the evolution of eukaryotes without this
this this probably would not have
happened so gold says tiny organisms
that exploited a wealth of co2 water and
sunlight transformed the art so these
are cyanobacteria they look like this
wide variety of habitats they are
morphologically diverse and some can
also fix nitrogen what I show here those
are supposed to be micron those were
that
the mac to pc conversion so they can be
very large like 10 micron bacterial
cells and unicellular whereas they can
also be in filamentous phase like in
anabaena a system that has been studied
the three in the bottom are the one that
can fix nitrogen cynical sister 6803
that's the war cards that we have been
working on for more than 30 years now
that does not know how to fix nitrogen
I'm going to compare in my this one with
that one sino tc5 1142 and 6803 those
two numbers that will come up over and
over again and you will know what I'm
talking about this one cannot fix
nitrogen this one can but both of those
are photosynthetic oxygen equal to
synthetic organism so let's go into sino
t see what I'm going to describe to you
is a project that has been ongoing for
more than 15 years now with this class
of organisms now let me go back and
point out something when nitrogen
fixation takes place in a photosynthetic
organisms as I pointed out one has to
separate out the two processes the
process of oxygen production and the
process of nitrogen fixation because the
two are the yin and the yang as I
mentioned now organisms have developed
two different strategies to do that it's
easy to understand one is over space and
that's this this kind of filament the
cells that are smaller there those are
the vegetative cells where
photosynthesis is taking place of cells
that are larger are the heterosis cells
where nitrogen fixation is taking place
so the two kinds of cells and elaborate
developmental processes that are taking
place has been very well studied over
the years this is separating out the two
processes in space in contrast what you
will see is that these kinds of
single-cell organisms that fix nitrogen
single-serve cyanobacteria they separate
out the processes in time and this is of
interest here and that's what the
circadian rhythm business comes into
play okay so cyano TC again here are the
different kinds of scientists am NOT
going to spend a lot of time
they have been isolated from various
parts of the world the what one that we
work on primarily Phi 1142 that was
isolated by Lucian man's Lab at Purdue
when they went out to port aransas in
Texas so these are from benthic water
and they are also found in open ocean
and very interesting stories that are
developing in how those sino tc's
operate in the open ocean okay now what
I want to point out here is that you
know it's the phylogenetic relationships
I know TC nowadays it's easy to sequence
the genome any any given evening you can
sequence a bacterial genome and you have
tons and tons of data and then you run
them through pipelines and then you find
out all kinds of things this is some
years ago in 2011 you're a majority of
the ones that were known and what I show
here is that cyano TC again that 51 142
and here is the other one that does not
know how to fix night what should be
very clear here is that the two are very
closely related in this whole scheme of
the things I'll come back to this this
notion in contrast there are other
cyanobacteria species like this cynical
caucus they are quite distant from a
phylogenetic point of view okay and this
will play an important role so let's
talk about 511 42 and what is an
approach that is being called now it is
systems biology which is looking at all
things that happen in the cells we used
to call this thing physiology in the
past so so that's that's what we are we
are going to go into but in much more
detail and with an approach that takes
into account the entire genome and its
associated functions ok so it's
unicellular and fix this nitrogen
diurnal rhythm results in numerous
intracellular changes and in this
electron micrograph what I want to show
you is what a cyanobacterial cell looks
like it's a typical gram-negative
bacterium has an outer envelope player
with the plasma membrane and outer
membrane and inside is this whole
elaborate network of membranes that the
thylakoid membranes that the same kind
of straw membrane system that's
presently in chloroplasts and then it
has all kinds of other things in
intracellular body one that is being
studied at this institution very much is
this one called carboxy zone where
carbon fixation takes place and so on
okay so let me first show you the
cellular ultrastructure Michele
libertine when as a graduate student did
this study and it's a 2 nanometer
tomographic sliced images that show the
intercellular details showing the
thylakoid membranes how they are laid
down and G here is glycogen bodies or
glycogen storage bodies see is carboxy
zone and so all of these are shown and
these are our individual slices shown
one after another when you put those two
together this is what you see there is a
there is a movie associated with it but
I will not go into the complication is
again mac to pc conversion but what you
see here is this elaborate description
this is still the the largest or the
most detailed description of a
cyanobacterial cell to date basically
what it shows the entire cell this is a
cutout and it's full with those green
colored pseudo coloured membrane system
that's the thylakoid membrane so if you
look at that cell that a typically coli
cell and a typical cyanobacteria cell
that will be the distinguishing feature
the intercellular membrane system that's
Tyler Cloyd also we counted numbers so
there are 21 peroxisomes and so on and
so forth okay all right so this is what
a cyanobacterial cell looks like okay so
now let's go into the business of
dynamics or rhythms what happens to
these cells under alternating light dark
conditions I'm going to stay away from
considerations of circadian rhythm
that's a set of studies that I'm not
going to talk about there are some
subtle differences between diurnal
rhythms and circadian rhythm studies but
if anybody is interested I'll be happy
to discuss that later on so diurnal
rhythms we set up experiments that are
very very simple it requires 12 hours of
light that's the L side the left side
and 12 hours of darkness that
move side on the right side and
basically the first thing to observe is
that when we look at it specific time
points during the light period in the
dark beer and we measure photosynthesis
here is darkness here is light and what
you see is that that capacity of
photosynthesis goes down dramatically
during the dark period and it comes back
up during the light period and in
contrast nitrogen fixation takes place
exclusively in the dark period okay
that's thus the temporal of separation
of the two processes so basically what
we did in those early days is take
samples every two hours which means that
there are a whole bunch of undergraduate
students who have lose their circadian
rhythms and they collect all of these
samples and what was interesting is that
this system is so robust is that you
know looking at the data you can
immediately say okay you know this
person at two o'clock in the morning did
not take the right sample because of the
oscillations that take place in various
things that you saw so anyway so
collecting those samples and those
samples were then used in a variety of
the same samples were used in a variety
of omics level studies so to say but
first let me show you what happens to
the organization of the thylakoid
between light and dark this is in dot
darkness d ten that's ten hours into
darkness this is el 10 this is light ten
hours and what you see is that here the
thylakoid membranes they are relative
orientations change but two different
kinds of intracellular bodies that are
present here is glycogen granule that
accumulate during the light phase
because that's where active
photosynthesis is taking place and the
carbon is getting stored in the form of
glycogen in the dark phase as you will
see in a few minutes that glycogen is
broken down that's actually the engine
that drives nitrogen fixation and the
nitrogen that's fixed goes into this
bodies that are called cyano fising
granules and that's the storage
area for our the volume for the fixed
nitrogen which is subsequently used in
biosynthesis during the following day so
it's a going over and over again through
these processes in a periodic diagonal
manner so it's a beautiful system and as
I have mentioned photosynthesis and
nitrogen fixation are separated
temporarily in the same cell okay so now
comes into now looking at all different
kinds of molecules I'm going to spend a
lot of time on transcriptomics but we
have done transcript protein metabolites
post-translational modifications all of
those but basically with the same
samples so that we can compare the
different omics level data one with the
other so let's talk about
transcriptomics well the first thing is
that nitrogen is gene cluster night rod
nitrogenous this enzyme is large it
requires a few protein that are that are
components of the nitrogenous enzymes
but it also requires all sorts of very
unusual cofactors the details of which
we are beginning to understand and for
to synthesize and insert all of those
cofactors into nitrogen is there is a
large set of genes that that are
necessary and in many bacteria by the
way bacteria archaea are the only
organisms only pro carriers can fix
nitrogen there is no you carry or death
known that can fix nitrogen so in sino
tc5 1142 there is this large set of
contiguous genes in gene clusters a
whole said that's looking left word and
a whole set that's looking right word
all together 35 genes i will come back
to this business of 35 genes and
different sino tc's have practically the
same type of organization of the NIF
cluster okay so let's first look at the
expression profiles at the transcript
level of all of these genes and what we
found is really very tight coordinate
control of the expression at the
transcriptional level let me describe
this to you this is a law of 2 ratio and
there is a 7 I'm sorry 9 log difference
between the top of that and the bottom
of that
okay this is dark period this is like
period again dark and this is this is
light okay so all of these genes are
getting coordinate lee controlled coming
all from this cluster of this 28,000
base pair chunk of DNA that's present in
sino TC and you can see how tightly they
are controlled we have continued these
experiments in subsequent years for many
many days and that does not die away so
it's very carefully control okay now if
we take the all of the transcriptome
data and we do modeling on those by
doing very simple Pearson correlation
coefficients and looking at what are the
different genes that have the same kind
of expression profile over a diurnal
behavior then you come up we came up
with this this kind of a model that that
we call this a read model okay what let
me describe this these are different
time points dark one hour five hour nine
hours this is light one hour five hour
nine hours red is up-regulation four
times and this this faint blue color is
16 times downregulation ok now let's
look at this area all of these actually
show all the genes that are present in a
cyanobacterium in this case the sine of
T c-51 142 so every dot represents the
transcription level for every gene okay
and that's invariant in or in this
structure what is variant are the levels
of expression so in the darkness what I
say energy metabolism basically
respiration that's coming up first
followed by nitrogen fixation but they
also go down to at the end of the dark
period what comes up is this region
that's photosynthesis the lights it's
lighting up and it is riding up really
high here but that also goes down during
the light period toward the latter part
of the light
so this is not just the presence of
light or darkness but a care food
programming inside the cell that
determines the transcriptional profiles
of every gene that's present in this
organism and based on those data this is
only based on the transcriptional
profile I want to emphasize that we came
up with this course cellular model of
the processes that are taking place
inside the cyanobacterial cell and it's
again very simple in this diagram on the
left I show all the things that are
happening in the light this is summing
up the metabolic processes that are
taking place and the right right part
are all the things that are happening in
the darkness let me describe this to you
even though this is a photosynthetic
organisms this bugs actually is very
active also in the darkness that's the
bottom line of this thing as it one
expects for the synthesis meaning both
the photo part the electron transfer
processes as well as the synthesis part
the carbon fixation processes are
extraordinarily highly active in this
part the carbon gets fixed and stored in
glycogen as I mentioned and in the
darkness then the glycogen is degraded
the glycogen degradation pathway turns
on and then restoration comes up at a
very high level that takes away all the
oxygen from inside the cells we have
direct measurements of these and then
nitrogen fixation takes place but it's
not just nitrogen fixation many many
processes such as hydrogen production
hydrogenous things like that are also
controlled in the same way so at in this
period of time the inside of the cell is
relatively anoxic and that's the unusual
and special feature of this kind of
cyanobacterial cells and then amino acid
biosynthesis happens here the extra
nitrogen is stowed away in sign of icing
and it goes back and this continues to
happen over and over and over again so
the diurnal cycle summarizing that
photosynthesis results in oxygen
production during the day
high rates of respiration generated low
intracellular oxygen tension during
early night hours and oxygen sensitive
enzymes such as nitrogenous can then
function in the same himself okay since
class is my host I thought that I should
at least touch on the next topic which
is proteomics as I said we have done
this interrogation at different levels
now we all know after many years of
systems biology that mapping one omics
level map onto another omics level map
still remains a challenging thing and
and that's simply because from very
basic biology there is no reason to
believe that what happens at the
transcription level will be essentially
followed at the level of all the
post-transcriptional translation and
false translation event so we were
interested in seeing what is the level
of correlation between the diurnal
oscillations or if there is any diurnal
oscillation so same kind of experiments
it required a little bit more time we
did this experiments in collaboration
with Dick Smith and colleagues at pnnl
and in those days these were really
challenging experiments it kind of tells
you what we have done but basically the
same thing every two hours we we collect
the sample the same samples that were
used for transcriptomics and this is
what the cycling patterns of the
proteins look like same kind of color
scheme okay so the first thing to notice
is that that the reed is not that dense
so don't not that many proteins at the
level of detection that we had are
oscillating in their in their absolute
protein levels and but the overall story
is the same again photosynthesis comes
out during light and nitrogen fixation
comes up in the in the dark time and
here is a description of what happens at
an overall protein level and we did this
experiment this was at that time a super
expensive experiment to do all these
things over all these time points but we
decided to do it at least for two cycles
to just to see what is repeatable
and just by looking at the profile you
can see that the same kind of profile
more or less is emerging day after day
and so 251 proteins exhibited measure of
measurable oscillations in their
abundance under alternative light dark
conditions who are they we go in through
there and basically without looking at
the details basically 25% of them belong
to central intermediary metabolic
pathway and nineteen percent are
involved in photosynthesis and
respiration these are proteins whose
absolute amounts are changing over the
light-dark cycle but let's go back to
nitrogen is not and here is again
something really really interesting here
the transcript levels of all of the
genes I show only the structural game
sniff hdk and other two other genes just
to make it simple and see how they have
very tightly controlled a single peak in
the middle of the dark period but during
the dark period it also goes down and
I'm emphasizing this because there's a
story behind that that we do not have
much idea about it but biology does it
this way it does not there is a program
that determines that things will come up
during a period of time and then things
will go down during the same apparent
dark period or light period here is what
happens with the proteins and as you can
see it's the proteins are also getting
degraded they get synthesized and but
they get degraded during the night time
and their levels are extraordinarily low
in the light period also there are
binary oscillation profiles if anybody's
interested we can talk about that those
are interesting stories by themselves so
during the scion tc diurnal cycle the
regulation of nitrogenous the NIF genes
are expressed during the dark period
need structural proteins are synthesized
during the dark period we have done
dynamic proteomics which shows that the
new proteins are degraded during late
dark hours and in those studies what we
find is that post translational
modifications
important I don't have time to go
through that we'll be happy to discuss
that later on with you and nitrogenous
assembles and functions during early and
middle dark hours ok now comes the yang
remember the same cell is also
photosynthesizing and so the question
that we asked is it just darkness that
turns off photosynthesis or are there
extra exquisite control elements that
are present in the organism that makes
sure that oxygen is not evolved when
nitrogenous is functioning and what I
will tell you is again a snapshot of
only one of many things that are
happening exactly in that way we're thus
there is cellular control in protecting
the nitrogenous from accidental
production of oxygen from from
photosystem 2 that the oxygen producer
so in photosynthesis for the system to
is the enzyme that produces oxygen we
know a lot about this system class just
just reminded me of those early days
when we did not even know how to isolate
these things and then over the years it
has gone gone to the stage where we
haven't 1.9 angstrom resolution
structure that looks like this and all I
can say is that ps2 complex is extremely
complex it has lots of proteins but and
it has also lots of cofactors the ones
that are important here that I'm
pointing out here are for manganese ions
we have known from early studies in sign
up with sign of bacterial cells with
people like George shenae from the 1960s
where they have I looked at how
manganese gets inserted in photosystem 2
how that gets functional and so on and
so forth now the reason i pointed out
manganese is that at the center this is
a cartoon diagram that simplifies that
very complex structure at the heart of
photosystem 2 are these two proteins d1
and d2 d1 is the protein that plays
important role in coordinating those
manganese atoms in photosystem 2 and
those manganese atoms are absolutely
necessary for the oxygen evolution
activity of photosystem 2 okay so long
story short if you cannot bind the
photosystem 2 cannot bind manganese you
take away that possibility of oxygen
production by photosystem 2 if there is
a little bit of light around okay
because a little bit of oxygen is enough
to kill nitrogenous so do you want
protein that's encoded by this gene
called PS behaves well known gene
provides many critical ligands for the
manganese cluster that is at the heart
of water splitting and oxygen evolution
PSB a has five copies in sine of T C Phi
1142 and out of this five only one that
we call PS be a 4 that's just a
nomenclature all of the other four are
expressed highly during the light period
which is where the function okay so here
is light and those red lines actually
shows the sum total of all the four
genes of how they behave at the
transcriptional level we notice there is
a fifth copy this psba for that's
behaving just the opposite okay that the
red one is the one that's psba for the
other ones are the black ones are the
ones that are the normal p is VA so we
said this is kind of strange why is a d1
protein being expressed in the darkness
that has no business of being expressed
at that time because photosystem 2 is
non-functional at that time it became
clear when we sequence the g protein and
the protein part there are specific
amino acid residues that we know from
that crystal structure that an involved
in ligation of the manganese cluster and
nature has done that beautiful
site-specific mutagenesis experiments
some many many billion years ago in sino
t see where each and every one of those
residues are taken out and replaced by
things that in the 1980s and 90s many of
us were involved in doing site-specific
mutagenesis to find out which residue
change gives rise to non ligation
manganese so long story short we
recapitulate at this in cynical sisters
by taking this gene from cyano tcp SBA
for expressing it in a cynic assistance
6803 cell that does not have any psba
gene and what we find is that that one
the one who's shown with red cannot be a
students form but it cannot produce
oxygen this is expected but we show it
show it this way whereas if we take one
of those other genes the psv a one then
introduction of that into San into
synechocystis allows for resistant to to
function so what I'm telling you here is
that here is again and control system
now why do you need in the darkness and
then the other thing that I must mention
that when we looked at this specific
form of psba that has these amino acid
replacements they are present in many
dies of traffic sign of bacterial
strains and the list has grown
tremendously since we publish this thing
and we call it the same teen ld1 because
it is a way of the cells making sure
that oxygen is not evolved now why is
this important and this was something
that was discovered by Kim Wagner who
was a former graduate student now now
works at a local company she said well
what the the intensity of moonlight in a
full moon night and cyanobacteria are
growing on the surface of the pond and
did the simulation in the lab and
basically there is enough oxygen there
that kills nitrogenous activity in cyano
TC under those conditions is that the
real natural reasons we don't know but
that's one of the reasons probably the
sign of actually go to this extreme
control systems where they make sure
that for the system to is not it is a
functional at
time by putting in this strange copy of
d1 protein that cannot function as a
manganese ligation protein so we
envisioned we have some proof but not
definitive proof of this entire model we
are working on that basically in the
darkness dissociation of some other
proteins and synthesis and insertion of
sd1 that the sentinel d1 and then remove
all of SD one insertion of d1 when light
comes up these are challenging
experiments but we have initial evidence
that this is the way scion tc is
operating so this is the Inge and the
yang how much time do I have do I have
about five minutes or so ok alright so
let me just go into the next phase of
another challenging set of experiments
that we have embarked on now it has been
now close to three years now that we
have been involved in this and this is
the the project has to do with designing
nitrogen-fixing ability in oxygen in
photosynthetic cells and the background
that I provided to you with the
scientist and cynical sister systems
will make it easier for you to
understand where we want to go with this
this is an evolving story it's a it's a
collaborative one where costas Morales
is a computational scientist in a trap
Penn State and then two of my synthetic
biology colleagues in the engineering
school of washington university web
teamed up to do this well why even get
into this that's because nitrogen is an
essential nutrient for plant growth and
a long-term goal of this nitrogen
program is to endow plant cells with
nitrogen fixing ability this is the big
goal that ever of people are interested
in and as I mentioned photosynthesis in
plants produce oxygen important
inhibitor of nitrogenous but on the
other hand nitrogenous needs a lot of
energy so you cannot put nitrogenous in
a tissue that does not have enough
energy source it will not be able to fix
nitrogen so how do you deal with this so
the overall goal for our systems and
synthetic biology approaches is to
develop the design principles to
establish nitrogen-fixing ability
in the unicellular cyanobacterium
synechocystis 6803 and the knowledge
base that's created in this project will
be directly applicable to engineer
nitrogen-fixing craft plans we hope okay
alright so so this is kind of a
schematic diagram of what we are talking
about we want to make in nitrogen-fixing
crop plant there are two ways to do that
one is to engineer nitrogen-fixing
symbiosis for crop plants just like
soybean does it the other one is putting
nitrogen-fixing module directly into the
photosynthetic tissues of the plant okay
so one way to think about it is that we
just heard all these things about sino
TC 5114 to just change for all that
entire machinery into plans this is
challenging so we did not even approach
this instead we said let's just take a
shortcut and let's try to figure out
that the the principles that are
involved in putting in nitrogenous into
an oxygen environment in an organism
that does not know how to fix nitrogen
so we go to our good old friend
synechocystis and we want to transfer
the nitrogenous program not just the
genes and proteins but the program
itself all of it into synechocystis
makes in ecosystems that's dies or
trophic and then the design principles
presumably in some future years will be
used for making this nitrogen fixing
plan that's the basic thing okay so we
chose these two organisms simply again
being back that they are
phylogenetically very closely related in
many ways sinica sisters is a nitrogen
fixing cyanobacterium which has lost its
ability to fix nitrogen that's the way
people have described it in papers that
describe that the phylogenetic
relationship and our goal is to
establish in synechocystis the nitrogen
fixation circuitry normally present new
scion tc what i'm going to tell you in
two minutes is that the first phase of
it is over because we have been able to
now this was the biggest challenge at
the beginning of the project is this 35
genes in nif cluster put all of these in
a move them from sino TC into
synechocystis and there are new
technique
that are used by the synthetic
biologists that allows us to do this so
we we could take we could use a method
called DNA assembler that again the
details are not important here but if
anybody's interested I will be happy to
discuss that and very quickly first of
all put together an e.coli first in East
and then in e.coli this large plasmid
that's about 40 kilobase fear that has
all the genes here exactly in the way
cyano TC has it we decided to take this
approach rather than the traditional
synthetic biology approaches that Chris
void and colleagues are doing which is
first taking apart every gene putting in
control circuits on them and putting it
back together and make it work we
thought that we are not clever enough to
do that so just borrow the whole thing
from a cyanobacterial cells move it into
a cyanobacterial cells it took a little
bit of time but we could transfer all of
this into synechocystis and for the last
two years this thing is stable
replicating in synechocystis growth is
not compromised because of the
production of all of these genes and we
know at the transcriptional level all of
these genes gene products are made all
of this 35 I also show you another
contract where we have now started
whittling down the 35 and we have now
down to 24 and we have it down now to
even 10 I'm not going to show you those
data but basically what what we the
stage that we you are we are right now
is that silicosis is 63 6803 can fix
nitrogen so basically what it shows here
is that here the three genes that make
the three structural proteins of
nitrogenous with HD k in plans only one
of these the iron protein has been
expressed in chloroplast with great
difficulty because of again this bad
thing called oxygen so at every level of
the production of the functional
nitrogenous there is oxygen control in
negative manner and what we see here is
that in
this organism where we put in all of
this we can have transcription of nif
hdk the black one actually shows the
whole setup 35 jeans and I show you this
truncated version 24 which has subset
appreciably higher level of
transcription level for all of these so
there are some negative regulators here
and I will not go into the details of
that but important thing is this this is
the first time to our knowledge that in
a in an oxygen ich photosynthetic
organism one can establish the nitrogen
fixation machinery and so you could see
that there is production that that's
taking place nitrogen fixation let me
also point out because I usually this
question comes up this organism is still
not die as or trophic because the
control circuits are not appropriate in
fact this bug the cynic assistance that
has this nitrogenous genes it produces
the nitrogenous at the wrong time namely
at the beginning of the day because
that's the normal program inside the
cells we have had recent success in
providing some control elements in this
cell to make it go the way cyano TC goes
but we are still quite some distance
from achieving the stage where a robust
nitrogen fixation cycle the diurnal
rhythm is expressed in sino TC this
project is the first part of the project
that I talked about on scientist systems
biology is a collaboration with Lucien
minute for the University and a whole
bunch of people led by dick Smith's at
pnnl Pacific Northwest National Lab and
then for the nitrogen fixation project
in science and in synechocystis these
are the four groups and all the people
who are working on there
here is my research group and airy
creatures may still remember rebstock
halt it's a right in front of the that
at our lab and I thank you and I thank
you my close collaborators designer
bacterial cells I'll take questions it
was a beautiful setting and I like to
ask and I might ask in the beginning you
show us the diameters of the different
and the civic assistance was smaller
than
the ones that do all the great stuff
does that body difference have any
ramifications and getting the diurnal
nitrogen fixation no simple answer is we
don't know that are yet look very hard
or sets that are not small there are
sign of pieces that have been found
insulated by John's air scoop
who's that had much smaller size
but those are the special services that
have fun too
and carbon fixation
they are
cells that live together within elders
edge and then the story is more the
algae this is arvin
and that special like science
in that case cells are massive
so that your knee correlation we have no
idea but we have to encounter case that
question
yeah so there are a lot of really
interesting examples of regulation of
things happening in the dark or light
that started before the you know the
next phase actually occurred is there a
readout of the nutrient state in the
cell and somehow you know nitrogenase is
starting to shut off what glycogen is
running out have you measured the
glycogen at different point said nice
and yes yeah yes so grandpa Jim runs out
and but it's not strictly correlated
with just the level of drivers basically
it all comes down to the central control
element X form is acting as PT protein
in bacteria that senses the relative
levels of carbon nitrogen all of that
story in works fine here but what is not
known is how the central oscillator of
scienter bacterial cells which is very
well-defined to the work of suitable
inner colleagues or coyotes are you see
how is that controlling this entire
program and we don't have an answer to
that but you know some of those
specialized regulatory elements are
involved in figuring out the entire
program this in the complex
a lot of oscillating systems have
negative feedback loops and I'm just
wondering if you could elaborate on
evidence for or against such a thing
going on so in other words the synthesis
of an enzyme reaches a certain
concentration that then begins to shut
down the synthesis at that level again
we don't have any understanding at this
level but dismissed at the level of
transcription there is a lot of evidence
so they are odd negative feedback that
are set up as well as positive feedback
those regulatory elements have been
identified by us and others and so one
of the places I can I where we know
quite a bit is this business of how the
level of
that transcript and not talking about
proteins of nitrogenous go down during
the dark shades
it has to do with elements presently
that you know that gave rise to small
practice consolidation that going that
get expressed exactly at that
and we haven't proven it completely but
the idea is that that then gets turned
on the whole business of in this kind of
rhythm is whole question of anticipation
of it one and we see evidence of that in
every step of the way the cell knows
when I come on
by synthesizing more than the transcript
protein
of all the photosystems the cells know
that oxygen will be coming out at that
time so my Japanese is it goes down and
data they also
I believe that there were many such
confidence
we do not have much idea but as far as
the enzyme levels and a feedback on that
just one follow-up have you kind of
duplicated some of these experiments
where you've extended the nighttime or
the daylight period yes I guess we were
talking about some of those we have got
all the displays expewience 18 6 + + 20
24 I can tell me people 20 power supply
than four hours of doctors this one
doesn't work and it definitely doesn't
work by four hours of identity or
darkness there is a range in which it
works basically I can summarize that
those studies by saying the problem as
long as you have sufficient amount of
glycogen back to the store then nitrogen
fixation does take place but in doing so
we also figured out that we can separate
out the two central processes
destination and nitrogen fixation during
the dark period quite a bit or unfrozen
depending on the length of library
so those are classic time series
experiment
it has ecological implications debts of
investment may be related to that
partners which time it takes
transcript exactly
energy if you have
synthesize and remove your machinery
which is costly
energy costs so I
you playin service might be right you
play with the amount of life
factoring down in our energy and
accumulate you see similar well not in
great detail but we have measured ATP
and nadph tables in these cells and
those change predicted as we expect
based on the energy but as far as you
know what is the cause and effect
you should that there's an ortholog of
the central d1
vanya in other side of bacteria is that
also family
for class and if so what we came back
yeah well it's hard to tell what the
exactly of is if so and their bags at
that question but we coordinate that
with saina bacteria that can fix manager
as opposed to realize that
w
so how much conservation of these
variant Camino assets is there a
customer that has the central people
yeah it said functional arrived
somewhere actually let's say we take it
is it yes very gassy to site-specific
mutagenesis experiments done in bad we
know that as far everything is changed
in uncharted kissimmee or even when it's
changed to glutamate that compromises
madman is like being interested in
functional what we find is that that
those changes are different in the
different sd1 sense more like nature
took the canonical T is the way that
makes the normal game body and then made
to specific changes things so that we no
longer can live in matrix but they are
not the same changes
infestation the better for the bacteria
or the bacteria tuition from the late
for the infection of 15 to be predation
the hurricane don't occur
again my answer needs to be annoyed it
doesn't have to be
proteins and mean and they just stare
out and what's the need for making them
so you know one way that I have used
many times is that the first hour of
blackness beginning of light for my
charges like every day that's what
happens in Maine and then assembles
functionality but they can be played and
they will be grid that time station why
that is necessary and whether that is
absolutely necessary in the circus that
we're putting sisters we don't have an
answer but the triangle ends
so I really don't have an idea of why at
fiji islands
probably not
about 80 tagging systems of torque
sufficient education like Archie
transformation
discovered I being phosphorylation dusty
when you are official anymore yet so the
blubins plane
no visual analysis than women yeah so
that glow means that bind like you know
probably that by yourself on my rope
that binds oxygen inka being system that
i described they are used to actually
sequester than oxygen so that local
conservation officer in quotes down in
Mississippi is only one globin gene and
that has nothing to do with this is
similar for science so that's not that
it is so it is a bad
and that actually didn't suppose that
cannot account for the local haunts me
karate kid when you're in line
photosystem 2 is working is super high
principal that maybe I discovered and
they speak
is there a specific machinery and
resistance for harvesting hydrogen that
okay so you're talking about already
fixed nitrogen like nitrate or ammonia
how does it do that is the sender thing
bass tab which is transported
in fact something that
here was pointed out that the audience
that fix nitrogen they actually sense
that very very well so if we put in even
micro molar concentration of nitrate
into the scion tc cells not thinking
session definity goes down over a matter
of
bombs so if hdk synthesis stops and
again the curtains so we don't know why
that happens but when there is enough
fix nitrogen the organisms do not do
this is well known from other occasions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu